[Music]
what up guys it goes in for anime uproar
here with a video about your favorite
waifu c2 first and foremost i want to
shout out to spooking all de-animate for
giving me the idea for this kind of
fact-based video I thought would be a
lot of fun to make one myself and it
definitely was links to both of their
epic channels will be in the description
below without further ado let's jump
right into it number 1 c2 has many
nicknames in code geass including
immortal which pizza girl zeros woman
zeros mistress and which of Britannia in
nightmare anomaly manga Cheshire Cat in
a very plot heavy OVA and that's not
even counting the other manga
adaptations not only when you her real
name damnit a tail what is it what is it
number 2 c2 Japanese voice actress or
say you you cannot Naga me who also did
Khanna from Inuyasha Tessa from Full
Metal Panic and Mei Ling Li from
cardcaptors Wow we're all a mystery but
when zipping my evil was over the power
was set free God Kate Higgins
does English dub and she also did Sakura
from Naruto and saber from six-day night
holy [ __ ] does this mean that c2 is King
Arthur but hey that's just a theory and
anime see number 3 c2 is a very popular
character she was chosen as the most
popular female anime character of 2007
and 2008 at any major magazines annual
Grand Prix while Uche was voted the most
popular male character c2 is also the
12th most popular female character on my
anime list and 43rd most popular anime
character overall while Lelouch rests
comfortably at number one with over
60,000 votes to put this in perspective
my precious Colin is the next most
popular Cody Asche
character all the way at 191 despite
mine and Animax
heated wiper war over call and close
with keys yeah it is clear that for the
majority of code geass sans c2 is number
one number four let's go over some
character stats c2 is five foot six
inches or 168 centimeters tall c2 was
born on July 26 which would make her a
Leo that actually makes sense since
wheels are supposedly driven by the
desire to be locked in c2 his greatest
wish was you know to be lumped which is
why or Geass made all those around her
fall in love with her unconditionally
her year of birth is unknown but we
could speculate she is dressed as a
Portuguese Jesuit and running up the
darkness manga and the Jesuits were
banned in our timeline by the imperial
region Toyotomi Hideyoshi
in 1587 because they were considered a
threat to national unity at this point
c2 is already tired of living and wishes
to die which would suggest that she has
been immortal for a good while
given these back I'd speculate that c2
is at least between five or six
centuries old
during code geass lelouch of the
rebellion number five what's with the
straitjacket c2 keeps wearing the
straitjacket from the research
laboratory even though the louche wants
her to stop because one might find her
and think he's keeping her as a prisoner
or at least that he's into some kinky
[ __ ] in one of the audio dramas c to
reveal that the reason she keeps wearing
it is because she is not free she is
shackled to this world so the choice of
clothing is appropriate
however significantly enough during our
- she mainly appears in her black
knights uniform which is notably
different from the uniforms of the other
members and the most similar to zeros
own uniform with the gold outline this
suggests that c2 is a lucius accomplice
or equal and not just another follower
also considering that c2 clearly puts a
lot of thought into the clothes she
wears this change in r2 seems to
symbolize c2 is growing passion -
Lelouch and in turn reflects the fact
that she no longer sees herself as a
prisoner number six
c2 is overpowered as far it's no
coincidence that in chess the queen is
where
the most points usually around ten aside
from the king of course was worth a
spectacular sideways eat this is because
the queen is the most powerful and
versatile piece that being said it's no
surprise that c2 is often considered to
be Lelouch is Queen even if we ignore
the fact that c2 gives a loose Geass in
the first place
c2 has so many other tricks up her giant
fleece she's extremely intelligent when
the chips are down she knows where to be
at the right time to save a Lucia's act
she also knows how to pilot virtually
every nightmare frame old or even
brand-spanking-new model she is immortal
over the centuries she has been killed
many times in a variety of gruesome ways
including but not limited to regular old
gunshots spear wounds burning at the
state guillotine the iron [ __ ]
Maiden and also water pressure in fact
you cannot see to save in a conference
said that during her fight with Jeremiah
in the Siegfried c2 was crushed by the
water pressure but managed to come to
the surface it was too gruesome to show
on TV Mao even suggests that she would
still regenerate even if he cut her into
compact pieces and stopped her into a
suitcase I mean holy crap this chick
could probably survive a spirit bomb
next when she makes contact direct or
through a nightmare frame she can feed
them hallucinations of chaotic and
ominous images this ability also draws
on the memories of the target to create
customized and personal nightmares this
is called the merging of consciousness
and she has used it on Suzaku and by
accident on Lelouch but with Lelouch
Lelouch saw her memories rather than the
other way around c2 is also able to
cancel the effects of a Geass this is
seen when she kisses Ellucian the first
episode of r2 and releases him from his
father's Geass it is believed that this
power was the reason that Bartley was
studying her and that he successfully
copied disability and created the Geass
canceler which he implanted in Jeremiah
this makes me wonder if not only finally
was able to open her eyes because c2 his
constant presence in the house might
have fully released her from her
father's Geass to that's just
speculation but I hope they explore this
ability further in season 3 and finally
c2 s code allows her to detect people
who are connected to Geass
and those who are important to the Geass
wielder through this power she can
detect where Lelouch her contractor is
from a distance and where not only is
because she is so important to Lelouch
this is how she figures out that not
only is oncoming the island at the end
of r1 I could go on but I think you guys
see what I'm saying here c2 is a badass
number seven
there was actually a code geass article
that ranked a boob size of all of the
shows female characters c2 came in 12th
place after all of these well-endowed
characters Shiva surely you fee mia
rakshata feast cecil no results the file
book what is it
sisal sicily was to feel there we go
that was harder than it should have been
Valletta Cornelia Ino Colin Mariana and
Lily
however many fans have come to see to
defense and pointed out that c2 would
get first place for and I quote nicest
ass number eight although c2 expresses
little emotion throughout most of the
show and it's apathetic to most people
she does express emotions in the
presence of Lelouch she cried for
Lelouch in the final episode and in
Renia of the darkness manga she also
cries for - who just so happens to look
exactly like Lelouch
I also have an AMD that focuses on this
vulnerable side of c2 because I love it
which I'll link for you guys in the
description below
number 9 c2 has entered into Geass
contracts with many people over the
course of her lifetime
hundreds of people according to her c2
has given Lelouch now Marion and Layla
their Geass power in Rennie of the
darkness she also tries to give Renia
Geass but the contract fails and he
grows a grotesque mechanical arm instead
that feeds off of living things also in
renting of the darkness c2 reveals that
there is in fact a limit to the number
of contract that she can have at any one
time
although we still don't know what that
limit is once again let's hope that
season 3 gives us some answers
number 10 c2 has apparently come
into contact with quite a few famous
historical figures in nightmare of non
Limon uh it is revealed that situ served
under Henry the sixth on the English
side during the Hundred Years War and
fought against Joan of Arc who led the
opposing French side also in a special
DVD feature c2 and Lelouch discussed
Washington's rebellion a failed version
of the American Revolution c2 suggests
that she was close friends with both the
George Washington and Benjamin Franklin
perhaps he too even helped Lelouch come
up with the name for the United States
of Japan and that's it guys I hope you
enjoyed this tax based kind of video
this one took a bunch of work but I also
had a lot of fun maybe too much fun but
I hope you guys learned something new I
definitely did while researching it hit
that thumbs up button to let me know if
you enjoy these types of videos and want
to see more of them in the future
and feel free to leave any suggestions
for future videos in the comment section
below if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
for more anime videos until next time /
9cu space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]